a romantic attraction from the start
kristen stewart said they were young and
stupid what does that mean she explains
it all and what robert pattinson is
really like not everybody climbed aboard
the twilight train with its glittery
vampires themes of forbidden love and
questionable ideas about women the five
movies based on stephanie meyer's four
books received mixed critical reviews
and their rotten tomatoes tomato meter
scores range from 25 percent for the
twilight saga breaking dawn part 1 to 49
for the first twilight movie however the
franchise did well enough in theaters
between 2008 and 2012 to become a bona
fide hit and a genuine pop culture
sensation if you were a tween or an
adult with questionable priorities in
the late naught twilight was probably a
major part of your life for better or
worse you could also say that twilight
catapulted reluctant celebrities kristen
stewart and robert pattinson to stardom
the young actors previously had
relatively low key careers except for
when pattinson portrayed said rick
diggory in harry potter and the goblet
of fire a role that actually brought him
to the attention of the producers of
twilight in the first place stewart and
pattinson had enough chemistry to carry
the film and even dated for several
years as a result of meeting on set it's
totally gorgeous obviously
but apparently nobody here is good
enough for him
years after the final chapter hit
theaters stewart opened up about
pattinson's on set behaviour explaining
why the two got along so well on the set
of their blockbuster films in a new
yorker interview in 2021 kristen stewart
swooned to show her reaction to robert
pattinson's audition when she said it
was so clear who worked she also
revealed that the two had similar
approaches to acting in the first movie
as stuart told the new yorker pattinson
had an intellectual approach that was
combined with i don't give a [ __ ] about
this but i'm going to make this sing she
recalled telling pattinson that she felt
the same way the actress then pointed
out that the two were not overly
experienced in the industry as she was
just 17 at the time and pattinson was
21.
how long have you been 17.
a while
stuart continued and whatever we were
young and stupid and not to say that we
made it so much better but that's what
it needed and that's what anybody
playing those parts needed to feel their
similar viewpoints contributed not only
to the success of the twilight films but
to the couple's budding romance today
stuart is about to marry dylan mayer but
she still appears to harbor sentimental
feelings about her relationship with
pattinson during the 2019 interview
after howard stern noted that dating
your co-stars might be a mistake stewart
said simply there was nothing i could do
on a recent episode of the big hit show
podcast director catherine hardwick
shared her side of the story she spoke
about the difficulties of finding the
right leading man for twilight
describing the character of edward
cullen as ethereal brooding and iconic
upon auditioning robert pattinson at a
home in la though hardwick quickly saw
that he would be the right edward to
stuart's bella swan whom hardwick was
building the movie around and the actors
apparently clicked immediately during
that first audition pattinson and stuart
performed a bedroom kissing scene one so
passionate that pattinson fell off the
bed hard work explained i'm like dude
calm down and i'm in there filming with
my little video camera whatever and at
the end kristen was like it has to be
rob but i could tell they had a lot of
chemistry and i'm like oh my god
this chemistry easily translated to a
supportive feel between the actors on
set film editor nancy richardson
recalled i just remember seeing in daily
scenes where they would do a take and he
would throw a tree across the meadow and
then stomp away kristen would go up to
robert and say that was great what was
wrong with that kristin was kind of like
his encouraging coach all the time when
he seemed to feel as if his performance
wasn't good enough you know your mood
swings are kind of giving me whiplash
richardson noted that the dynamic
between the two was real and translated
well to the big screen fortunately fans
of the series can relive all that
chemistry whenever they desire and yes
it's pretty much always the right time
for a twilight marathon
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]